thanks Carter
Marcel up
you're on the wrong pattern belching
life and nothing kami it's not your job
to do the technique
these partners liven up with yeah this
is it reaches class
and you can that standard still is in
there get it stabbing you so obviously
there's a class thing
you're bracing on your elbow you won't
work with me you'll get hurt that way
class
going faster is in what keeps you can
moving stop contesting for space and
okay will move so Tristan raincoat
christen your noggin come in rain
see his stop he stopped moving his feet
then they contested for space she
stopped moving
he got overridden it's a simple equation
go same thing happened to you range
should you be standing still and waiting
for okay done in conjunction you're
racing her that's not it either
be mindful of your clashes be mindful of
the openings you're giving that was like
a clash
there's just standing still Maya
make it work everything works go see
you've given a lot of pressure on it
okay so he's covered in what twice made
contact with his elbow not here but over
here in space and he comes in he tells
you where you step
not a program I always do it like this
okay so you go ahead you feel that whoa
hey go
yes Luke is teaching you to break your
pattern
hey partner so ease the lease march love
you that takes forever to find a new
partner and go when we don't love one we
want something to stop where we did in
ninety someone okay are you tapping so
why should I stop are you going to tap
or try some
you see this arm is already weak can't
see it
songs not on her centerline and her
elbow is out you see you look at her
posture
so there you go what
let's do it it every time you see every
time it comes off center so instead of
going here why don't you move your body
around it
yes no honey what you have a multitude
you - whoops so I'm in full balance
right
you see it again it's the same problem
you're gonna lose that letter this again
go who can teach us not yet
whoops
what's your what was the solution rather
than move your hand around move your
body around
watch my hand don't move my hand from
outside the end my hands in front and
I'm gonna do my part
take my can I forget have an elbow
she's not the entire teapot
do you have to experience all about
sharing is through kids you're just
coming in
little rap should look exactly the same
there are three ways to the outside of
the elbow
to the outside of your space
you feel openings you don't give up you
see and you don't get your heart broken
come on
this is terrible right there that step
debri disconnect then what happens when
I enter in your jack come on every time
really very try some mouse whoops
you will cost you down here with the
little kids so you have had to go up
because your feet didn't go back you see
there was a knife involved you didn't
change the distance you closed it go